Thank You Marilyn that was amazing
there's a lot of student teachers in the
room who might have been reflecting on
your own schooling experiences and it's
actually really hard because I suspect
that most of you were actually in the
top mask loans and actually may not be
really aware yet of the challenge that
you're going to have teaching some of
these students who are struggling with
mathematics quite a few of you haven't
been out in your for your first
professional experience yet so you
probably might be wondering what's in
store I'm hoping that you'll get to chat
to some of the real teachers during the
day and they'll put your mind at rest
and I'm hoping that some of the real
teachers will be able to offer to take
you on your professional experience and
help you to actually do these sorts of
things but Marilyn can I say thank you
so much for coming down from husband I
know you're very busy and you've got a
lot on your plate as head of school but
we really do appreciate the fact that
you've come you've joined us to help us
launch this fabulous community of
practice so thank you very much p for
Marilyn sits down we have time for some
questions so this is your opportunity
what would you like to ask I'd like to
hear your comparison in that project
between the fully qualified secondary
mathematics teachers and the other field
teachers and how they reacted to what
you asked them to do that's a really
questions you're thinking of him I think
initially I found the outfield teachers
more open to some of the ideas that I
need to engage them because they didn't
have a prior professional history in the
distance and I think that tends to
confer on a more open frame of mind but
over time the qualified maths teachers
deep mines it just took time the other
difference that I often noticed in that
project and in the other projects when I
work with teachers now work with
teachers from first year out and in fact
in that particular project I had a
number of my own graduates who who
turned up so that was really lovely
including one from the first group I
taught in 1997 through to the last three
by told in 2007 another interesting
different side notice is that it's often
the beginning teachers who are very open
and willing to try new ideas again you
know the more experienced is not this is
not hard and fast it's not all
experienced teachers are unwilling but
again that changes over time as well so
time is important very important in
professional learning that teachers are
allowed time to think about their
practice and what they might try time to
try things and fail because that's what
happens when you try something new it
doesn't go right the first time and it's
the same for me as a teacher and a
teacher educator you try something the
first time it's a dessert or disaster
just doesn't work but but what matters
is what you do next what you learn from
that so that's very important message
for pre-service teachers and early
career teachers here this is a very
fruitful time in your career where I
hope that you will be willing to to try
out new things
because you will find experienced
teachers in schools who will support you
in that and I've also been very very
lucky to work with the experienced
teachers actual the ones here i was
saying who love having pre-service
teachers and they're getting teachers
comfortably school because it's
energizing because you're young
enthusiastic full of new ideas your
presence is a former professional
development cresperians teachers
absolutely any more questions or
comments or reactions John
we kill them after the end of senior
secondary school consists of only one
course no I don't jam not around the
world although i suspect i know i have
to check with finland but why would one
interesting piece of research I came
across which doesn't entirely answer
your question I'm and I think it's
because because mathematics is itself is
such a diverse discipline and there are
so many different kinds of mathematics
that help students go to different kinds
of destinations so I don't have a
problem at all with having different
types of mathematical symbols think
that's entirely probit but there is an
interesting study that looked at the
mathematical achievement of students in
different countries based on whether the
country had what was it a curriculum
where everyone followed the same pathway
those are the curriculum that was
submitted and differentiated you know
different different tracks in this study
showed that there was higher achievement
in the countries where there was no
differentiation well there's no
differentiation of the curriculum now
that's not a causal relationship that's
very important to understand there may
be other complex things going on
but no it just seems to be possibly
because of the nature of the discipline
and at some stage students have to start
specializing you can't state school
forever working out what we want to do
so it has to happen sometime no I'm not
aware that's a minute there are dealing
yes actually I think there is I think in
the UK system there mei system rather
than having a hierarchy of two unit
extension one extension to they have a
suite of course as everyone takes the
same fundamentals and then they
specialize whether they want more
statistics were modeling more pure
mathematics some so I think in effect
they have actually broken down the idea
that the courses have a hierarchy and
they've been doing that I think for
about 10 years it's a motorized
curriculum value yeah they've much
around it's a very good curriculum well
but actually got colleagues in the UK
would say one was first introduced it
was a disaster for mathematics because
you do actually require some
prerequisite knowledge to do to do
mathematics in the senior secondary
school you can't start from scratch I
think that's another reason you know why
you get specialized subjects there as
well yes so you do there is a pathway
thank you